sébastien nadeau bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france on parle déjà d'un rapport
accablant extrêmement sévère avec l'état
sur les migrations quelles sont les
conclusions vous tiré de ce rapport
peut-être juste rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être présentée sur ce théâtre de
marionnettes entre gérald darmanin et
boris johnson jeu je suis désolé mais on
est dans un moment où il ya une urgence
à gérer imaginé il ya un incendie un
immeuble il ya des gens qui sont dans
les flammes et qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire on est en train de monter
ce spectacle entre des gens mais on
s'occupe pas pendant ce temps-là de
l'urgence il ya une urgence aller à
calais la grande synthe elle est à bien
des endroits sur notre territoire et
pendant ce temps là on monte on continue
de monter un grand spectacle médiatique
sans s'occuper de ceux dont on a à
s'occuper parce qu'en france on a à
s'occuper des gens qui sont dans le
dénuement des gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
c'est cesser le préambule de la
constitution française il ya eu tout un
débat sur l'identité nationale de notre
pays sur les questions migratoires et
personne n'était allé chercher dans
notre héritage celui des lumières celui
de d'après 1945 qui nous dit quoi qui
nous dit un français n'est avec des
droits en france et à l'étranger et un
étranger n'est avec des droits à
l'étranger et en france ça veut dire que
à calais par exemple les droits humains
ne sont pas respectées c'est ce que nous
dit ce rapport tout à fait les droits
humains ne sont pas respectées à calais
le autant une expulsion à sa légalité et
donc on peut considérer une expulsion
comme quelque chose tout à fait légale
il ya la justice qui passe d'abord mais
la manière d'expulser et ensuite le
suivi qui les fait là par contre on sort
complètement du champ du droit français
marlène schiappa parle de mise à l'abri
mais enfin ce qu'on fait c'est que on
sort les gens de leurs tentes on jette
leurs tentes on leur dit partir ailleurs
et puis ça s'arrête là on l'aimé pas du
tout à l'abri ça veut dire qu'il faut
accepter l'idée que finalement à calais
dans cette région il y aura toujours des
migrants et il faut l'accepter c'est à
dire que le démantèlement de la jungle
de calais finalement ça n'existe pas
c'est ce qu'on peut conclure il sera
temps écoutez moi j'y suis allé à calais
la jungle
elle a été
non pas démanteler la jungle de calais
elle a été disséminé mais le problème
c'est que les gens qui sont toujours là
sont dans un état tel qu'on peut
considérer qu'il ya une urgence une
urgence humanitaire dans notre propre
pays
cette urgence humanitaire
un certain nombre d'associations de
collectifs solidaire tente au mieux de
parer aux insuffisances de l'état et
qu'est-ce qui récolte ces associations
finalement des contraintes ils sont mis
en difficulté par les services de l'état
très régulièrement dans leurs actions
vous savez il a été rappelé pas plus
tard qu'en 2018 que la fraternité est un
principe à valeur constitutionnelle
donc là on est en train de passer
complètement à côté du sujet
boris johnson gérald darmanin qui font
je vous le disais leur presque intégral
mais il ya une question humanitaire en
france c'est quand même fondamental il
faut revenir sur cette question d'abord
parce qu'il ya 178 millions d'euros qui
sont utilisés pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine cet argent
sert à quoi finalement quand on voit les
difficultés que vous décrivez qui
persistent à calais oui alors 178
millions d'euros c'est pour la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale sur le
littoral du pas de calais et du nord
mais il faut prendre en compte tout cas
ça s'ajoute l'argent public des
collectivités que ce soit qu'alex soit
grande synthe qui qui qui est aussi de
l'argent des français qui est mis là et
on a
bien plus encore que la somme que vous
annoncez et avec cette somme on n'est
pas capable d'organiser un service
minimum
minimum vis-à-vis de ces gens dont on a
des obligations
on a des obligations c'est le droit
national français qui nous dit qu'on a
des obligations vis-à-vis de ces gens
donc il y en a qui sont en situation
irrégulière il y en a qui sont en
attente
effectivement d'un passage vers la
grande bretagne il y en a qui
souhaiteraient demander l'asile mais ils
peuvent pas le faire est en tout point
du territoire on a des problématiques
d'accès aux soins
des problématiques d'accès à
l'administration des problématiques
d'une justice complètement emboliser et
donc on se retrouve avec des magistrats
qui doivent rendre des jugements pour
des dizaines de personnes chaque jour
ils peuvent plus faire leur travail
correctement vis-à-vis de ces
populations on a un embouteillage des
tribunaux administratifs ont un
embouteillage de la cour nationale du
droit d'asile bref la justice n'est pas
accessible non plus pour ces gens si
pour ça que quand je parle de
maltraitance d'état c'est que à tous les
endroits où on regarde on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a toujours le droit
inférieur qui leur est appliqué et ya un
droit il faut l'appliquer et du coup
quelles sont vos recommandations après
ce rapport déjà en amont quelle solution
voir avec la crise qui joue en ce moment
la frontière de la pologne et puis
l'urgence sur le terrain vous
recommander quoi aujourd'hui alors il y
en a plusieurs mais d'abord il faut
c'est un principe évident il faut
traiter l'urgence quand il ya un
problème humain quand il ya cette
situation humanitaire qui se dégrade de
jour en jour il faut déjà paré à
l'urgence ça c'est le premier point et
je dirais ses inconditionnels et on a
les moyens de le faire on est la france
quand même faut arrêter nous raconter
n'importe quoi sur le sur ce sujet mais
après ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que quand on parle de phénomène
migratoire on parle d'étrangers et quand
on parle d'étrangers moi je suis désolé
mais
voyez qui parle des étrangers qui parle
des phénomènes migratoires le ministre
de l'intérieur mais enfin le ministre de
l'intérieur il s'occupe de l'ordre
public et de l'insécurité en france
il ne sait pas il ne peut pas il n'a pas
la compétence pour comprendre les
phénomènes migratoires et les gens qui
sont dans ces services ne peuvent pas
intégrer un certain nombre de nécessité
par rapport à ce phénomène qui délivre
les visas pour venir en france le
ministère de l'intérieur mais que fait
le ministère des affaires étrangères
dans ce pays s'il ne gère pas les
affaires des étrangers donc on a un
problème de pilotage dans ce pays qu'il
dure au moins depuis 2007 parce qu'avant
le ministère des affaires étrangères
avait vocation à s'occuper des étrangers
donc vous voyez il ya vraiment une
réorganisation des services de l'état
mais il ya surtout un sursaut de de
conscience de la classe politique des
médias et des françaises et des français
ce sursaut c'est de dire nous avons
affaire à des êtres humains avant
d'aboyer et puis dani mais je ne sais
quelle peur à leur sujet ces gens y
viennent ils ont des valeurs il existe
ils ont une existence ils ont un passé
il ya des gens très bien comment se
fait-il qu'on les considère comme des
animaux juste avant noël quelques
secondes il ya aussi la population
locale qui portent le fardeau de cette
situation il faut pas les oublier non
plus mais bien sûr mais
c'est un problème
évident suffit d'aller à khaled de voir
ces pauvres gens tous les ronds-points à
attendre on ne sait plus quoi mais il y
a les associations et s'il ya quelque
chose à faire dans ce pays c'est que les
services de l'état se met à travailler
vraiment en partenariat avec les
associations avec un objectif de
fraternité celui là il existe et je
pense que les populations locales elles
accepteront beaucoup mieux la situation
un grand merci sébastien nadeau d'avoir
assisté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
député du groupe liberté territoire
président de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur les migrations à un
rapport présenté cet après midi